6 23 here on a tuesday morning we're
less than a week away from the tax
deadline that means some of you some of
us are going to be scrambling to get
your filing done on time so what do you
need to know when you're getting all
your paperwork together joining us this
morning is janelle king district manager
at jackson hewitt to talk about all the
tax stuff janelle good morning to you
so here's my impression of what i do
when i'm giving taxes
help i just i'm like here i don't know
what to do help me uh people are gonna
be like that a lot right now absolutely
why should people know especially here
in las vegas if they're with all the
pandemic
the funding that was out there and the
unemployment insurance that was going
out what should people make sure that
they have locked in before they go and
see a tax professional absolutely well
the biggest thing is not to panic i know
we talk about the countdown it's almost
here the 18th is coming up quickly but
you definitely want to make sure that
you file now make an appointment with
your tax professional get in as soon as
you can to avoid any kind of delays or
penalties with the irs so you definitely
want to make sure you file and this year
because of some of those circumstances
with coronavirus
there are some differences for a lot of
folks out there that they probably need
to be prepared for that wouldn't be that
way in the normal tax year absolutely
what are they well here especially in
vegas when you're talking about things
like cash tips or any kind of benefits
from self-employment you definitely want
to make sure that those are taxable
income so even if you didn't get a w-2
or 1099 you still want to make sure that
you file okay and
preparation is key right when someone
shows up what what do they need to give
to you what what are the questions that
you're asking them like all right look
thank you for showing up we appreciate
that but you're missing this this and
this you need to have this this and this
give it what is the itemized line here
what we need to bring along well of
course that's individual to everyone's
circumstance but at the same time that's
why you want to make sure you get in
early you want to miss the rush what
comes up you know easter weekend on the
18th so depending on the individual but
as soon as you call we can run that down
for you any tax professional can let you
know everything you need you know i in
past years i know we've spoken with the
irs and one of the things they try and
warn all of us about is scams and things
to watch out for ways to protect
yourself what are some of the things
that that you guys have seen at jackson
hewitt and others uh
things to watch out for yes well scams
normally happen at the beginning of tax
season but never hurts to be prepared
for next year just know that if the irs
is going to contact you they're going to
do it by mail so any kind of phishing
emails or calls you're getting it's
probably a scam so you might want to
watch out for those all right
it's a it's a busy time obviously just a
quick final thing people need to know as
we're getting down to uh tax deadline
time to hustle right it's the hustle
final things people should know before
they sit down at their dinner table and
start going through the numbers the
biggest thing right now is make sure
that you file early don't wait till the
18th do it soon and don't panic and make
sure that you actually do file you don't
want to miss the deadline and ask
someone who knows what they're doing and
do this help with my taxes please yes
you know thank you for coming in this
morning i really appreciate it thank you
for having me 6 26 here on a tuesday
morning next